panel politique chantal hébert michel
david et pas de journées bonsoir à vous
trois
comme on vient d'en parler puis je
voulais en parler à la fin mais je vais
en parler tout de suite ça vous dérange
pas de l'impact de cette crise
non bon c'est pas que pas que les
résultats ont été chamboulées en alberta
mais quand même un petit mot sur ce qui
est en train de se passer au québec on a
connu un changement ministres aussi ou
tout début de la crise qu'est ce que ça
vous dit chantal sur les suites l'autre
cette crise politique en alberta on
n'est pas du tout dans le même scénario
qu'au québec
la raison pour laquelle monsieur calligé
quelqu'un parle de support c'est parce
que jette du lest parce que son bateau
est en train de couler il ya beaucoup d
observateurs qui s'attendaient décidé de
se rallier après avoir dit le contraire
un passeport vaccinale que qui aurait
des défections et c'est pas ce qui s'est
passé et c'est une mauvaise nouvelle
dans le sens où de plus en plus
concentrée que le caucus de monsieur
canet se dit pourquoi est ce que nous on
s'ennuierait dans un autre parti alors
que le problème est à la tête et après
les élections d'hier le mpd est arrivé
deuxième hier en alberta avec 19% du ca
c'est juste un très faible écho de la
montée du npd sur rachel naples et
l'ancienne première ministre qui est
deux qui a devancé les conservateurs
dans les intentions de vote alors
sérieusement
monsieur cannes et change son ministre
de la santé pour dire qu'aujourd'hui il
exécute quelques uns mais dans le fond
c'est lui qui est vraiment menacé et
mathieu nous en parle depuis plusieurs
jours ça va vraiment mal on sort des
malades de la province paul michel on
est débordés complètement les lits de
soins intensifs sont débordés le
délestage le rappelle c'est 100% il n'y
a plus aucune opérations non urgentes en
alberta un paul ça vous dit quoi
touchant mais ça nous dit que monsieur
qu'il n'y paraît très mal parce que
contrairement à d'autres premier
ministre qui semblait être de bonne foi
qui dépassés par des problèmes
structurels
réseau de la santé comme au québec où il
y avait tout l'enjeu de la pénurie de la
main-d'oeuvre qui avait aggravé les
conséquences de la pandémie monsieur
qu'est né lui c'est directement son
leadership qui est en cause
souvenez-vous il promettait le meilleur
était de l'histoire de l'alberta ils
riaient des experts des médecins qui lui
disait ne fait pas ça ne m'était pas fin
à toutes les mesures sanitaires parce
que vous allez en payer le prix les gens
lui disaient c'est irresponsable et lui
il rit d'eux il est traité d'alarmiste
et ils disaient les gens qui nous
critiquent c'est des gens qui ne
voudrait pas que la pandémie se termine
ce qui est assez absurde je pense pas
qu'une seule personne qui regroupait la
pandémie se poursuivent encore et
monsieur kenny en sort très très affecté
avant on voyait en lui l'homme fort du
conservatisme canadien et il est dans
une position de départ pu changer
général est à genoux il est à genoux
instruments puis demande l'aide du
fédéral puis ça va changer un peu les
relations entre monsieur trudeau et les
provinces parce que ce monsieur kenny
qui va revendiquer haut et fort une
grosse des transferts en santé tout
c'est autre chose en ce moment il est en
train d'implorer la liste secours du
fédéral il pas dans une position de
force
est-ce que ça hue on a parlé la semaine
dernière un impact sur o'toole
michel
certainement c'est inévitablement c'est
la marque que conservatrice au grand
complet qui a été ternie par ce pass en
alberta ça me semble clair il y aune il
s'est quand même 15 % là je comprends
que la distribution des chaînes peu
tellement changé mais c'est 15 % de voix
de moins que les conservateurs ont eu en
alberta s'est passé pas rien bon vieux
peut-être le phénomène bernier à la
marge mais je pense que monsieur otto et
le recentrage disons 2 monsieur cannes
et 10g le recentrage de monsieur automne
mélangez tout ça et ça donne ça et le
résultat est la personne qui pense que
c'est le ministre de la santé qui agit g
malgré les ordres de monsieur canet
l'oeil est clair que tout le monde
identifier les responsables et monsieur
canet et comme dit paul vraiment
complètement vulnérable à tous égards
face à tout le monde et il mérite son
référendum sur la péréquation là qui
voulait tenir au mois d'octobre dans
laquelle il voyait probablement là une
façon de se remettre un peu en selle
mais si c'était pas le bon moment de
faire une élection générale le pensez
vous qu'un référendum en alberta
maintenant c'est une bonne idée je pense
monsieur monsieur k nous devons
réfléchir un peu j'entends juste une
précision comme
[Musique]
les élections
là-dessus le problème de jason collins
et qui va se présenter une table des
négociations s'il obtient un mandat avec
les égos crédibilité serait en fait même
au sein de la famille conservatrice est
enfin devenu un pestiféré et en penser
qu'une bonne nouvelle pour erin autour
parce qu'ici il doit y avoir une fronde
contre son leadership ce à partir de
l'alberta et des rampes des ces
conservateurs plus purs et durs dont le
leader spirituel et stephen harper est
aussi des cinq années jessie mme kané
discréditer c'est pas la pire nouvelle
peau et renault tourne aujourd'hui
plutôt que la semaine dernière où c'en
était une mauvaise ce qui m'amène sur ce
qui est arrivé hier soir au pays je les
montre et on l'a tous montré tous les
médias l'ont montré la carte est à peu
près inchangée oui un du pourcentage qui
ont bougé issilame et l'a4 est
essentiellement la même je veux entendre
monsieur trudeau
qui a dit je vous ai entendu
je vous ai entendu ça vous tente plus
qu'on parle de politique ou d'élections
vous voulez qu'on se concentre sur le
travail qu'on a à faire pour vous
donc je vous vouliez pas d'élection il y
en aura plus
rapides comme ça chantal dans une
réflexion générale je vous ai pas
entendu depuis hier mois réflexion
générale sur le portrait politique
canadien ce matin c'est pas original
aujourd'hui déduire mais y'a personne
qui sortis de cette campagne lorsqu'il
ans j'ai gagné quelque chose ce qui est
quand même particulier ça s'est déjà
produit donné il ya personne qui a
atteint son objectif
d'autre part il n'ya pas plus sourd que
celui qui peut pas entendre parce que
monsieur trudeau et entendu qu'on
voulait plus entendre parler d'élection
il y aurait pu l'entendre avant de
déclencher la campagne cela dit si
j'étais justin trudeau et que j'avais
des grands plans d'avenir pour de rester
premier ministre pendant encore dix ans
je m'inquiéterais aujourd'hui parce
qu'il n'ya pas un observateur qui est en
train d'écrire que ça va être son
dernier mandat je vous probablement que
ça correspond à sa pensée à lui mais
néanmoins c'est assez clair il ya
personne qui dit qu'il va se faire
pousser dehors demain ou après demain
par son caucus on n'est pas là mais il
ya cette espèce d'idée au sein du parti
libéral qu'à un moment donné il va
annoncer qu'il prend sa retraite si dans
deux ans on est encore là et que c'est
pas fait là ça peut être un coup de fil
paul baysse si je pense que la prochaine
année monsieur autre louvre diriger un
gouvernement minoritaire très stable
parce que évidemment personne ne veut
d'élections mais si dans deux ans on
commence à être sorti de la pandémie
s'est vite souvenez vous on a eu des
élections en 2004 suivi 2006 suivi 2008
donc il rien qui dit que ça ne se
reproduira pas puis monsieur trudeau en
effet en ressort tout à fait fragilisé
il y avait des gens ont commencé déjà
même avant cette campagne a parlé de sa
succession donc ce bris leur va se faire
de plus en plus forme et non pas aux
faibles d'autant plus que à la
différence de monsieur autour monsieur
trudeau et dauphin présumé ou en tout
cas de potentiels successeurs qui sont
des personnes de grande qualité vous
assez compétent excusez moi vous dites
qu'il est plus en danger comme surtout
plus non mais pour monsieur autour est
en danger dans l'immédiat mais ils y ont
chacun leur défi particulier monsieur
autour lui c'est différent y a pas de
dauphin il ya personne de prêt à prendre
la relève lui c'est un défi très très
court terme il doit survivre en disant
c'est trop il va y avoir une campagne
électorale peut-être bientôt on n'a pas
le temps ni les moyens de faire une
autre course à la direction monsieur
trudeau sont des filles voit plus ça est
un moyen terme de s'accrocher après une
ou deux années
oui parce que méchaal s'il veut rester
il est quand même en place là vous avez
je pense écrit aussi michel dans la
catégorie tout ça pour ça oui oui
évidemment ça sera très original non
plus de dire ça aujourd'hui mais
monsieur trudeau si vous restez pour la
prochaine année il ya évidemment aucun
problème et il serait même que ce
monsieur trudeau va faire sa marque
avant de partir d'un drap qui veulent
partir là il ya une année là où c'est
évident que personne va vouloir le faire
tomber il va avoir pas de champ
complètement libre mellick les coudes et
passablement franches alors ça va être
drôle mais ton pour monsieur legault
parce que s'il pense que monsieur
trudeau est affaibli le piquet llodra
pas faire grand chose mais ce monsieur
trudeau lasalle et ça va être exactement
le contraire alors c'est à surveiller
maintenant moi je suis aussi d'avis que
monsieur trudeau va voir infiniment de
misère est encore le chef à la prochaine
élection mais il ya toujours une
première rendant dans l'histoire et ce
qui m'a frappé
c'est que des fois monsieur trudeau
l'année sediba pire on se dit ok ils
avaient au bout du rouleau et tout d'un
coup comme on l'a vu dans la deuxième
moitié de la campagne il retrouve un
espèce d'air d'aller et ça m'a fait un
peu penser à jean charest soutenait ou
patrice qui des fois donnait
l'impression de tomber dans une espèce
de ne rester nil qui est bio se disait
si nick et la face
à une autre élection
japonais à tokyo le goût de partir leur
nom c'est parce qu'ils donnent comme
impression mais oui il y donnera poste
il donnera pas cette impression là mais
si par contre et décide qui va faire sa
marque parce que il veut partir nous il
va pas commencer à s'occuper des ce que
je vais gagner une autre élection il va
se sentir les deux mains sur le volant
mais les mains libres et d'histoire des
premiers ministres qui veulent laisser
un héritage c'est qu'ils se préoccupent
pas beaucoup de ce qui va arriver à leur
parti une fois tu comprennes
je vous l'avais dit deux choses là
dessus mais dites moi j'entendais
beaucoup dire de la part de candidats
que l'idée rockeuse et on vous aime vous
mais votre chef on commence à être un
peu tannique donc tout ça ne dépend pas
que de la volonté de monsieur trudeau et
parfois ça peut être intéressant pour un
politicien de partir selon ses propres
termes au lieu d'attendre que les
électeurs ou que ces militants lui
montre la porte alors on verra et bombay
venons à monsieur ou toulon va coûter un
petit extrait hier parce que cet après
midi à répéter essentiellement la même
chose on lui veut rester ça c'est clair
puis 10 il y en avoir mais sa version
partie faut qu'on soit prêt si jamais
dit elle dans 18 mois monsieur tour de
relais jouer à la roulette
alors sous texte à son parti la spartan
m'hamed d'art tout de suite michel david
avant de commencer à parler de l'unité
du pays effectivement monsieur août où
devrait se préoccuper de l'unité de son
parti
je pas convaincu qu'ils vont élever les
pattes leur nettement parce que très
souvent ce qu'on met remaniement
ministériel c'est facile de mettre
quelqu'un dehors mais à condition
d'avoir quelqu'un mieux ou d'aussi bon
au moins pour le remplacer et il me
semble pas en tout cas que c'est évident
moment où on se parle maintenant c'est
au tour bon clairement il n'y a pas
réussi son pari de recentrage et il y en
a perdu en alberta les gagnants des
maritimes mais au total les
conservateurs sont encore dans
l'opposition alors il va y avoir une
grosse
conversation entre guillemets à
l'intérieur du parti conservateur mais
je peux prêt à dire que monsieur o'toole
va être renversé c'est la prochaine
élection
mais on se souvient que avec monsieur
chirac sa vait pas été très long od
lendemain de sa défaite qu'il ya des
gens entre autres au québec qui disait
le chef nous ennuie c'était un moule est
entre autres à cause dossier de
l'avortement cette fois au québec et
dans les provinces maritimes les gens je
pense vont être assez
solidaire de monsieur autour la grogne
pourrait venir de l'ouest sauf qu'ici on
peut faire un lien avec monsieur kenny
l'alberta est en train de montrer au
conservatisme le danger de revenir aux
vieilles divisions des années 90 sur lui
forme et l'alliance canadienne entre
autres puis on a vu une droite divisée
ça ne va jamais les a aidé à prendre le
pouvoir mais monsieur autour a fait un
appel à ceux il le dit j'ai fait des
petits gains mais il faut continuer à
élargir ses gains vous avez vu dans son
discours il a particulièrement parler de
vancouver du grand toronto et du québec
où c'est là que des conservateurs
doivent doivent gagner encore plus de
votes et ils veulent en faire revenir au
pouvoir vancouver toronto en tout cas ce
cessez incontournable et chantal est ce
qu'il à l'espace pour croître encore où
on va le pousser
le problème ne parlait d'une élection
dans 18 mois sexton arme à double
tranchant non sens où ce qu'ils veulent
qu'ils partent et ils sont nombreux et
ils sont nombreux au caucus vont se dire
on n'a pas beaucoup de temps alors
disposons de son leadership et aux
dernières nouvelles monsieur autour va
demander au caucus de beauté sur son
leadership plus tôt que tard dans un
premier temps ce qui peut que ce soit
parce que vous êtes charest parce qu'on
avait dit hier je pense qu on parlait
d'un congrès au québec en 23 mai c'est
bien avant tout cas que ce que ça va
jouer c'est au caucus parce que on a
adopté au caucus cette approche du
député michael chang qui fait que si on
se plie à ça il va y avoir un vote sur
le leadership de monsieur o'toole au cac
ce qui pourrait le sauver c'est que les
conservateurs entre maintenant et
bientôt de plus en plus en ontario vont
penser aux élections provinciales qui
sent bien dangereux et vont se dire est
ce qu'on veut avoir beaucoup de
turbulences alors conserver là dedans en
même temps et à monsieur canet qui et
puis dans ce qu'on connaît cela dit on
parle quand même d'un parti dont les
membres votants pour plus qu'un tiers se
revendiquer de la droite religieuse et
ont déterminé l'issue de la course sur
les deux chez parle on n'est pas en
train de parler
nécessairement de du conservateur qui
pense aux résultats de l'élection autant
que dès l'aube et qui ont porté monsieur
autour de pouvoir au sein du parti
conservateur vous parler d'élections
dans les provinces sur le go pense à la
sienne at il perdu ses élections et hier
devant tant de monsieur legault et
l'opposition à québec
ceux qui sont choqués je voyais mélanie
joly
qui tienne compte fait la majorité des
québécois
veulent qu'on protège les champs de
compétence de québécois ils veulent
qu'on protège notre unis veulent qu'on
protège nos valeurs et d'éthique je
pense le message de québécois il est
très clair j'ai défendu l'autonomie du
québec je vais toujours toujours
défendre l'autonomie du québec
le grand perdant de cette élection c'est
françois legault françois legault a
parié gros et il a perdu les résultats
d'hier soir sont en retour à la réalité
pour françois legault françois legault
avait fait le choix du parti
conservateur du canada
hier soir en majorité les québécois ont
fait d'autres choix françois legault a
perdu ses élections et je pense qu'il
doit on prendre notre temps tout est là
at-il perdu ces élections en mai chez
naville bah oui évidemment monsieur le
voit perdre ces élections mais c'est pas
une catastrophe là je vous signale qu'au
moment où on se parle contrairement à
monsieur trudeau lille est encore à la
tête d'une majorité et tout indique
qu'ils voient à trouver une autre dans
un an alors il est pas en perdition là
maintenant ceci étant dit il est clair
que monsieur l'euro aurait aimé un
gouvernement conservateur plus
conciliant à ottawa qui lui aurait
permis à lui d'arriver à la prochaine
élection en disant ben vous voyez j'ai
une déclaration d'impôt unique mon
second 3 d'y amener votre jus dessus
c'est vrai j'ai un tunnel j'ai des
nouveaux pouvoirs en immigration bon ça
ça arrivera pas mais monsieur legault
nous a démontré au cours des derniers
mois qui il est excellent dans le rôle
du défenseur de l'identité bafoué par
des méchants rock à ottawa
bah il va se servir de ce qui a été
capable d'en faire très bon usage et sa
voix et ça ça lignes de force d'ici la
campagne et pendant la prochaine
capitale alors c'est parce qu'ils
auraient voulu mais je ne pense pas
qu'ils soient en dépression aujourd'hui
loin paul icre et des caps il dessine la
carte la prochaine élection québécois
oui c'est vrai parce que si on regarde
sur le fond si on prend les enjeux un
par un les gaines qu'il aurait eu avec
les conservateurs sont son prix non mais
regardez par exemple les transferts en
santé on le dit c'était c'était vraiment
des pinacles ce que les conservateurs
avaient donné plus durant le prochain
mandat on parlait moins d'un milliard
par an x pour beaucoup dans le budget de
la santé puis régulière mais c'est au
tour s'engager seulement à renégocier la
hausse des transferts en santé mais on
n'a aucune idée de ce que ça allait
donner même chose pour les pouvoirs en
immigrant si on me suis auto l'avait
jamais dit qu'ils allaient les accorder
il a seulement dit qu'il était ouvert
par un négociant et ouais c'est ça puis
pour ce qui est de la loi sur la laïcité
moi je pense pas que si fédéral décide
d'intervenir à la contestation qui est
déjà encore faut-il le rappeler je pense
pas que ça va se passer avant la
prochaine campagne québécoise donc des
points de freiner les points de ce que
monsieur voir gagner les conservateurs
ses posters ans et jusqu'à libéraux vont
regarder monsieur leubou la prochaine
fois qui leur demande quelque chose ils
vont dire mais à quoi ça nous sert de
plaisir quand vous revirer de bord pis
vous torpiller notera surtout les
avez-vous surtout ont bouclé ce qu'on
disait plutôt si monsieur trudeau dans
son esprit fait 1 2 en deux ans et demi
puisse en avoir lui veut dire regardez
là vous avez pas marcher sur les pieds
j'en verrai pas quatre milliards chantal
pour le tunnel entre qua non mais là
c'est le bloc québécois qui devraient
être soulagés de des élections parce que
monsieur autour la légère mais gagner
plus qu'un gouvernement minoritaire les
libéraux et les néo-démocrates avaient
jamais beauté pour l'argent du troisième
lien et le ca aurait été bloc québécois
qui auraient été pris entre ces deux
feux je vous fais quand même un calcul
c'est pas une dynamique favorable pour
monsieur le dos si monsieur trudeau et
ses yeux sur ses intentions en santé 158
plus 24-25 néo-démocrate ça lui donne
une majorité au faire passer ça la
chambre des communes et ça c'est la
dynamique françois legault voulait
éviter surtout que ses alliés d'autres
fois je n'aurais pas dans le sens de
l'autonomie en santé avec des élections
qui s'en viennent en ontario jessica
n'est pas en état très bien merci
beaucoup à vous trois bonnes soirées on
se reparle très bientôt au revoir merci